I still have to walk down the street
alone at night not knowing what could
happen we have been like brainwashed in
a way if you get pregnant they used to
have shotgun weddings now they just have
a book so I do believe that women in the
1950s were better off yeah it will be
much easier for us to actually be in an
open relationship
um
no not open over what percent of Western
women are marriage material in 2023
hmm that's a really hard question yeah
first thing that came to my head maybe
25 25 percent
um probably 20 20 percent
was the question what percentage of
women are why football marriage material
marriage material
um
yeah under 20 under 20. what do you
think
I'd say 30 30 percent
I'd say about 15 percent
the way how things are going right now
is the last time breed so that's 20
percent
10 do you think women are better off in
2023 than they were in 1953
and tell me why yes or no and why
I don't think so I think this is just my
personal opinion
in 2023
you are better off
materialistically
um that's just the way Society is we
have to sort of fend for ourselves so um
you know if I really wanted to I can
work hard I can go out by Mercedes get
Chanel bag whatever but
you know
I still have to walk down the street
alone at night not knowing
what could happen you know and and like
you know the option to sit at home and
be a housewife isn't readily available
to me so I do believe that women in the
1950s were better off
just because life was simpler also like
technology wasn't around back then and I
think that
especially social media is the most
toxic thing to happen to us you know
we're we're more connected than ever
before but I think kind of what you were
saying like spiritually we're further
apart than we ever have been because
social media and and everything it's
just the front and you get to tailor
that front how you want to be perceived
um so yeah I definitely think that well
me personally I would have much
preferred to have been around in the
1950s
yeah I agree I definitely would have
much preferred to be around in that time
because you know things were just I
would say more
simple back then and just more
just I wouldn't say easier but just
there wasn't a lot of pressure you know
you you didn't have that much pressure
to prove yourself or you weren't
comparing yourself to people all the
time and you know you kind of just did
what you did to get by and you know
communities are stronger you looked
after your family and you know you
weren't distracted by social media and
you know what people were doing and what
people are wearing and buying nowadays
so I feel like we we have been like
brainwashed in a way and I would much
prefer to be back in those days to be
honest
uh I would say
um obviously we talk about gender right
now but
um for race
um I think in 1953 like it must have
been way harder for like black couples
to um
be able to even like function
um so and then 2023 um we're much more
aware by like race and like
um the effects that like black people
have like so for me to find a lovely
black man in 2023 I feel like
yeah it will be much easier for us to
actually be in an open relationship
um
no not open over because no I want to be
in a monogamous relationship but yeah
it's what you know to even hold hands
down the street without yeah so yeah I
think 2023
can you ask the question again
are women better off in 2023 than they
were in 1953 oh no I think like they've
really influenced by society and that
they're like chasing what Society is
feeding them
and like
when they actually get there they're so
unhappy because they've realized they've
wasted their life chasing something that
was designed to destroy them
I think that was always implicated from
the 1950s even till now it's always been
fashion there's always been up our
middle and lower class so people have
always been chasing some things you know
I mean to Bear themselves so me
personally I say
it's just more in your face because
we've got access to it you know I mean
certain people that what we're now
looking at and thinking oh wow they've
got this and that there's always been an
upper class middle class and a lower
class it's just more in your face now
and we more look at it like oh if they
can do it I must be able to do it it's
just you're chasing it quicker because
it's in your face but in
aspect of like fashion and everything
nothing has really changed I'll be
honest it's just more in your face it's
just more accessible but for me
personally I'm I'm happy in 2023 I think
social media makes women more delusional
yeah it does but it's in your face
that's right it's like they start
thinking they look like the filters
I hate it after Rochelle someone message
me off of Instagram I'll look at it I'm
like what the who is that 100 it's like
they start to literally think that
they're the filters and that the
attention they get from those filters is
equates to real life and it does it but
that just as human beings we've always
looked up like there's always been kings
and queens you know I mean like so it's
just more in your face it weren't
accessible like that like the rich used
to be around the rich the poor used to
be around the poor do you know what I
mean and if you did see rich person or
you'd look up to being that person but
it's exactly the same I'd say it's just
more in your face it's more accessible I
think that's what the company creators
are designed to do like the economy now
relies on the computer which influences
the outcome society as a whole I
actually think women are better off
today because they have no consequences
from bad decisions I don't think it
makes us happy but I just think like
before if you left your man you were
homeless now we have all these programs
to bail us out of every bad decision
that we made so if you look at it very
true I mean I don't think it makes us
happy just like it's kind of like if you
give a kid everything they want are they
really going to be happy at 18
I almost think women are spoiled in 2022
yeah 23 that's afternoon
I forgot
you agree disagree yeah yeah
you don't think women are spoiled in
2023.
oh no I think every they're super
reasonable oh okay this is a pretty
reasonable panel but I think it you know
you said obviously like are women better
off yeah I think I think yeah yeah I
think I agree they are like better off
yeah
um my answer was more coming from like a
personal point of view of what I'd like
and you're right it's about what what
would make us happy but if you're
actually looking at it black and white
yeah you're better off like if even if
you do go homeless or whatever like
starting early fans like we have that
option now or or it's like yeah if you
get pregnant if you get pregnant they
used to have shotgun shotgun weddings
now they just have a board
wow it's true yeah it is you know 40 of
women that have had abortions over two
or more
what are they going to have in the
future so it's literally a form of birth
control in 2023. yeah people use
abortions as birth control and it's it's
not great
I don't think it's great but I
definitely think we're better off in
2023 I don't think would have been able
to do this in the 1950s sit with a
woman-only panel and discuss topics so
I'm grateful that we're here they had
some actually I've been reacting to some
yeah it's like um there was uh but were
they like as as views yeah it was it was
well probably not as well I mean I can't
imagine if they had the views YouTube
that's how it is but I was watching this
debate I don't know if we do we post the
reaction of the debate of the housewife
versus the
you remember it was like a housewife
versus a career woman and it was so
interesting because it was the same
conversation we're having today but it
was literally it might have been the 60s
but like 50s 60s time frame but then
maybe it wouldn't be as diverse Maybe
I think we're better off now in 2023
yeah we've got access to more things but
it's like I think we're better off but
we're not happier yeah yeah I don't
think women the outcomes like leave us
happy and I feel like what you said um
social media the delusion I feel like a
lot of us well I speak for myself maybe
we spend so much time on social media
that we get distracted and we start
looking at what we see and thinking okay
this is what we need this is what we
should be doing this is where we should
do and in reality it's not like that
everyone's showing their highlights
nobody's showing what is really
happening yeah well and I think the
delusion is leaving us single and
childless yeah I mean who is a kid here
who's a kid you're a kid and they say 50
of women are going to be single and
childless by it's 20 30 so it's half of
us
like if we look in this room half of us
probably won't have kids soy sauce
that's already sad
I hope it's not anything but it's it's
but does that make people happy and my
grandma you know what's crazy my grandma
um she she's like pretty sick so I don't
know how much longer she's gonna live
but so I've been asking her like these
like deep questions I'll get them on
video and one of them I said like do you
have any regrets in life and she told me
I wish I had more kids and I said
Grandma you had nine kids
yeah how many did she want she's like
12. wow but it's like when you ask girls
I mean who here wants nine kids I
definitely wouldn't mind yeah no I would
have you would have nine kids 100 really
have you had one yet no but have the one
first and then come back to me I don't
even need to have the one like I've
already looked after children no I mean
child child
laborers
it's worse it's like I don't know a
thousand times worse what are my buddies
built for that it is built for that but
I don't know if you would go nine times
for that but it's it's interesting
because the conversation you guys are
having now that's like a modern
conversation because if I said that to
my grandma she would be like yeah no we
have more than nine
so it's kind of it's kind of just it's a
Testament of the times definitely yeah I
think I I feel like women really wanna
well there's a lot of people who
actually want to just work so I think
they're thinking that they don't want to
have that many kids just so that they
can still have that freedom and that
flexibility
um and there's a lot of women who
actually don't even want kids as well
and there is a study that said 80 of
women are not children
so the majority of women do want kids I
think it's yeah because if I I've had
girls come on the show and they'll say
oh I don't want kids and then my next
question is well what if it was with
this guy and there's always some say it
because they they're with someone that
doesn't want kids or they just feel like
they can't be your mother or they can't
get the guy they want to have kids with
that's true and so it's almost like a
coat no I don't I don't like I mean some
girls really don't
but it's I don't think it's a large
percentage of women yeah I wonder how
old those women are as well the women
who say that they they don't I'd be
interested to find a woman it's like mid
30s plus it's usually a COPE in my yeah
I actually I want to do a panel with
single childless women over the age of
55. yeah it's hard to recruit for that
though so if the comments want to help
me in London
that's specific on the panel but just to
get their point of view because I feel
like around like 50s women get more
based a little bit where they kind of
are not like you still get the 40 year
old saying oh I'm gonna have three kids
like when
yeah
body clock
um what is the number one issue facing
women today
not being raised in a two-parent
household yeah I got the issues Maybe
um safety not being able to walk at
night by myself I'm terrified I'm not
being trained to be a woman or a lady or
mother I have a question about that
night um do you think men can walk home
alone at night no no nice Peak for them
as well yeah I mean there's an age
bracket the way that London is right now
yeah no definitely not
um but I feel like there's just more
risk when you're a woman I mean
so if I get attacked and a man gets
attacked who's more likely to get help
from other men the women the women yeah
because someone might come across and
not even know who to help if it's two
men but with the woman like I feel like
people will automatically go to yeah
have you seen those videos of the woman
hitting the man and the Man hitting the
wall yeah and it's like they always help
the woman the man they're like good luck
yeah
yeah I don't know personally I just
don't feel safe on the streets
um I get Ubers literally everywhere or
you know someone will pick me up or
I'm terrified to walk alone by myself
just even coming here to tonight I was
terrified
I can handle that but I've actually been
followed home like I've been followed
home like you know I've had someone
trying to rob me I've had someone try
and touch me inappropriately you know
and it's it's a lot to deal with and
what area is that sorry to see
um well I'm from east London so wow yeah
just okay I don't know
um anyone else number one issue facing
women
I don't know if it's number one but I do
want to bring it up again I think
promiscuity is um
tainting us especially like now like you
know you're a similar age to me like
we've been on social media I don't know
about you but like I think I got
Snapchat when I was like 13. yeah so
it's like I know like before you had
like page three and things like that but
like
I just feel like things have changed and
like now you'll see like 10 year old
kids who are like like they'll just see
these like only fans models or whatever
like and it's just so like they don't
even blink like it's just so like
everyone's just used to it and Tick Tock
as well even like Tick Tock you have
like 14 year olds looking like they're
18 like you know moving their waist
around it's like like it's really scary
I've seen it it's really scary and I
just don't think it's gonna do anyone
any help in the long run men or women
like it's it's tainting everyone's view
of everything in my opinion 100 the
number one thing for women right now is
body image yeah yeah definitely body
image whoever is
having your waist your bombing your tits
your lips Botox is definitely body image
weave or whatever like
yeah yeah I feel it for you women
because like if you don't look a certain
way you're not doing it you know what
I'm saying women were worried about body
image then why are 60 of women
overweight in the UK it's worse it's
worse in America it's like 80 percent
but then you think I forget I feel like
sometimes um like even when you're over
eating in even if you feel like you want
to look a type of way
so even if you feel like you want to
look a type of way like you might just
eat it away yeah
then you gain weight by eating lunch I
guess but people are emotional eaters
that's still a choice that's true yeah
but also I feel like a lot of women get
into relationships or they get very
comfortable and they just start to put
on weight like just naturally I don't
know yeah
comfortable yeah and I don't know if
they call it like relationship weight
um but then you just take it too far and
then you really let yourself go but
you're like I've got to get in the gym
my point is I always hear women say that
like they care so much about beauty
standards but it's like if you cared
about beauty standards and why aren't
you 120 pounds I would say another
problem would be a lot of females are
emotionally unstable
that'll be another issue
to put all of that in a box yeah but
some people when they say they care
about their body image they're not
actually talking about their weight they
might just be talking about here how
their lips look how their eyes look how
so they're not focusing on their body
just think about this bit who has worse
beauty standards men or women
would you be like looking for or yeah
who is who is harder beauty standards to
meet men or women oh women women women
how so when women only swipe right five
percent of the time on dating apps and
they also find 80 of men is unattractive
I think men have it harder because the
chances of a man an individual Man
versus an individual woman of being
found attractive by the majority is a
lot lower for a man so like maybe like
they see the maybe like women we see you
know someone on I don't know like a
magazine or something we think oh I
don't look like her like sure that's a a
body standard that we feel like we have
to live up to but that's just how we
feel that's not the reality the reality
is we don't have to live live up to
anything really the majority of like
girls can find someone to partner up
with them sleep with them whatever it
may be whereas guys sure there might not
be a very obvious in your face you must
look like this but us girls as the judge
of men
um they've got way more to live up to
like the average guy like most of us
probably wouldn't mind I don't really
agree with that I feel like imagine if
only two women in this room were found
attractive by Men by the majority of men
that'd be sad
two very sad so how how can you say we
have worse beauty standards
like it's not it's not that it's not
even girls saying they're okay like they
deem 80 of men as unattractive not just
oh he's okay he's kind of he's medium
ugly
I don't think looks are looked at that
much when it comes to men I'll be honest
with you I think women look at status
they look at financial status they look
at where is this man at in his life also
yeah I mean obviously you have to be
attracted to the person that you're
dating but most of the time
personally me and like people that I
know the women in my life they have
never really looked at a guy and gone oh
he's got a really pretty face they're
like he's a man he's a man he's gonna be
tall yeah it's gonna be taller than you
at least a woman I've dated men who were
shorter than women and I'm a tall woman
yeah but you're not you're not the
majority and we're talking about women
in general women filter out men under
six foot on dating apps eighty percent
of the time
is they're normally like five foot five
and they're taking all the two men yeah
six foot two babies yeah yeah but
people's motives people's motives on
dating apps are also very questionable
and women most of women do go on there
as well just to get a bit of an ego
boost or have a free meal whatever like
and I I think that would be true if
that's not the number one way that
people were meeting today
um so you know if the outcomes weren't
relationships that's the number one way
then I would agree with you but
I don't know I just don't think that
there that we really like look too deep
into men's appearance that much yes we
like Kai I think we do look at the
height but I don't think we look at
always he's face perfect oh he's got a
double chin you know women look at stuff
like that we look at things oh my face
looks fat like oh I need to get a nose
job we look at it not men
so it's like it's like how are we gonna
like men don't care yeah but it's this
ideology that men like that typical like
Barbie skinny small waist petite girl
and I guess Society has kind of told us
that and we've sort of believed it and
the media also tell us that as well so
over the years we've just kind of we've
been brainwashed we we think that that's
what we love doing that listen to the
ass song in High School
yeah I feel like the skinny trend is
coming in now look at the Kardashians
look at Kylie Jenner she just got rid of
her BBL you know Kim's gone super skinny
yeah but none of them are wives yeah
that's true
like yeah they make money but they're
not wives that's true it's not it's like
women are changing for women they're not
even doing it for men if you ask men
what they want they don't want lip
filler they don't want your forehead not
to move they don't want a pound of
makeup they just want like natural light
okay can I ask you can I can I ask you a
question okay I hear what you're saying
but answer me this if they don't want
the girls with the lip fillers and the
big balms and the skinny little waist
why is it when you go down a guy is
following on Instagram every single girl
he is following looks like that girl do
men look at Instagram for wives candy no
it's no good for them they all want a
piece of it it's like if you look at
their corn Star Search is it is it going
to be the wife material okay they don't
want to imagine that but if they're
looking at people if they're looking at
women like that then they
somewhat find those women attractive no
yeah for the night yeah candies like
sweets I always say it's like sweets
because it is like you know it's no good
for you but you just want to really but
isn't that scary for when you get into a
relationship and you think oh he's going
to cheat then if he just wants a piece
of it and it's that good it depends what
kind of man you're going I don't know
people are so fussy about picking him
man just have a lower attraction floor
than us yeah so it's kind of like for
I've had guys explain this where they're
like if you're just above their like
minimum dating floor it's kind of all
the same to them I mean obviously
there's some girl like the hotter you
are the more you get away with in a way
that's what they say they're kind of
like the Richer they are for a lot of
women the more they get away with in a
way but no matter not nearly as picky
they're kind of like enough there's two
girls are more more judgmental to
ourselves than how men are judgmental to
us
yeah
it's interesting too I'll have guys like
rate girls one to ten just to like see
and they're always like very generous in
my like guys they just they're looking
for a reason to to qualify a girl not to
disqualify like we are yeah
okay
trust him
um
are abortion rights needed to create a
truly equal Society no
can you explain it a bit further like
what do you mean by abortion rights the
right to an abortion you guys have it
here up to six months but in the U.S we
don't it's an American channel so yeah
so our abortion rights needed to create
a truly equal Society
I don't even understand the question
yeah of course yeah
should abortion be allowed oh yeah you
shouldn't have a choice what of course I
am I think abortion should be illegal
and however I do obviously we have
common law in this country I do think
that there should be some kind of uh you
know common law
um where under specific circumstances
you might qualify for one but I think
the general standard
um legislation should be that it's
illegal and then under certain
circumstances or situations which like I
think they're pretty obvious we all know
um then it should be allowed and also
like if it's um you know if the child is
is gonna be born like disabled or
something I I do agree that maybe you
should be able to decide if if you want
to I don't know that's a really
difficult one I'm not gonna get into
that because I don't actually know how I
feel about that but generally I don't
really believe in abortion at all really
what about you
no I I would like to have that option I
would definitely like to have that
option
um things happen in life and you know I
might fall pregnant and I'm have you
fall pregnant
well I don't know things happen by not
being careful
like fall pregnant takes all the
accountability off of you if you yeah
but if I become pregnant yeah but if I
become my choice and God forbid my
husband lost his job and you know we're
not really great financially whatever
the circumstances are and we are not fit
to raise children of course I want an
abortion and I should be allowed to do
that are you typically with men that
don't have jobs and can't raise children
I hope not but we never know what will
happen in life you know so you you've
got to have I would like to know that I
have that option but you have the action
of contraception so why not pick that
option first and think preventatively
instead of um reactionally yeah
precaution not always 100 so I agree
things happen no that's 99.5 effective
if you get an IUD I had the
contraception pill and I got a child it
didn't work for me
like did you get the IUD and wear a
condom too I didn't I don't work I
wouldn't ever consider that with my
partner but I had the conceptive pill
and it didn't work and it's 99.9
effective which one did you take
um what's it called the morning after
bar yeah was it the five day or three
day one
um so long ago I don't really know but
it didn't work you took the morning
after pill yeah
I did that's like the last case result I
don't say contraception so like I did
take the morning after Bill and it
didn't work yeah but that's a choice to
not be on birth control yeah I don't I'm
not on birth control but which is why I
said I agree with you I believe that you
should have the option but I think the
options that you choose in terms of not
keeping a child
I think you have to I believe that you
should be able to justify them like if
she's not meant if a woman feels she's
not mentally stable to have the child or
for all the right reasons I think if
you've got options to do everything else
then I do believe you should have that
option that's my opinion up to up to how
many months oh no no I don't like it has
to happen immediately if you do if it's
like you've got a bump and I don't agree
with that I think that's wrong
so here it's up to six months do you
agree no no no no no that's too far when
do you agree with it immediately no
that's too far I think that's right yeah
immediately like as soon as you know if
you believe that you don't want a child
you've got to act really quick and I
believe that everyone's body's a bit
messy because so you might still be
bleeding you know what I mean anything
past like seven eight weeks and I I
don't I don't know just don't think
that's right yeah a lot of people don't
even find out until like after two
months I know a couple people that
they're like three months and they're
like this is your last day to choose I
have somebody asked me to take them to a
clinic in London when because I'm from
Birmingham when she was like six months
and I wouldn't wouldn't do that couldn't
do that
that's a full-grown baby yeah I
understand it's got a heartbeat as soon
as you're pregnant but that's a full
grown child you've had long enough to
decide and you understand like people
are completely against it I respect that
but I just don't I think the woman
should have a choice how do you not know
for two months
to me it's just being bailed out for a
bad decision it's just weird like at the
end of the day take birth control or
don't have sex
or don't sleep with or don't sleep with
people that wouldn't be good Fathers or
if you're not financially safe stable
yeah
if that's not as simple people
not having a baby but that's not easy I
don't think it's an excuse that people
have one night stands and I don't even
think that we should be saying like oh
people have one night stands to [__]
like it doesn't have to be a one-night
stand that's the way you get pregnant
though like it just happens and you
could actually happen you could actually
be in a committed relationship and then
an abortion whatever reason it could
happen that way but you can make choices
so it doesn't happen
but it doesn't change the fact that it
does happen but my whole thing is it's a
bailout for poor decisions because at
the end of the day if you get pregnant
you made a poor decision I agreed if you
didn't want to be pregnant yeah and
there'll be a lot more illegal abortions
though like people will be going to like
back corners and I think it's better to
do it the proper way well obviously
there's no proper way to think but like
the proper way is surgically everything
then to go to back Corners down
abortions are performed oh yeah they're
really nice
they pull off the limbs one by one so
they pull off the leg then we pull off
the next leg then they pull off the arm
and the other arm then they they crush
the skull and vacuum it out is that is
that true yeah that's true that's how
many months are like five six months you
can have that done like as soon as it's
gotten the other way the other way it
starves the kid and it like falls out
and I had a girl on the show explaining
her abortion at like two three months
and she said she was shocked by how
informed it was because it had like a
full head a whole I think she said it I
can't remember the exact stuff she said
but she said she was shot because a lot
of the pictures like they don't really
inform you of that yeah I thought I feel
like I'm on the fence to be honest
because I feel like everyone should have
the right to have a choice of what they
would like to do with their body however
like what you just explained to me I
don't agree with that because life and
um but what about the baby's trust so
what about the women right baby what
about the women what about the women
right in cultural Traditions who get
pregnant and if they don't get rid of
that child their life's on the line like
how would you justify that they are
responsible but they're also in a lot of
danger if they're gonna die yeah this is
what like this is what people always do
with the abortion arguments they always
usually extremes 99 of abortions are
elective but 99 so it's like you're
using the one percent argument to
justify the whole thing if I said okay
give you give you those abortions in the
life of the mother would you be okay
with Banning the rest
that are from poor decisions true I
understand I do agree with what you're
saying in terms of it being a poor
decision but I still think I still stand
with what I believe I agree
people make silly mistakes all the all
the time but it's not like somebody
that's sticking with them for Life yeah
and you know I know a lot of girls that
don't make the same likes and don't get
pregnant I just thought like people make
silly mistakes all the time
if you're irresponsible I also think
like you know you said about um like
Backstreet abortions and illegal
abortions or whatever I
sure Naturally that that might happen
but I also think it's possible that if
women don't have the option for abortion
they might be more careful because can
you imagine like if if we were living
like how we all are today
um and like let's say like you go out
clubbing you find someone you have a
one-night stand or whatever like I don't
know like contraception because I'm not
feeling like oh my God like if I had to
go in for an abortion like I just think
the fear of that like I think over the
last three years I've certainly gathered
that fear controls people and fear like
instills certain behaviors in people and
I think by not having the option for
abortion generally speaking say 99 of
the time
um I think women would just sort of wise
up we're not silly if you know that it's
going to be difficult to do something
you'd avoid doing anything that would
lead to that being the consequence
that's just what I think it's actually
true
I don't agree with abortion I just
believe that people should have a choice
I don't agree with it because I don't
think she'll take that last year however
I do believe that we should have a say
do you think that women should be
limited on how many abortions they can
have oh yeah oh definitely yes
definitely definitely because after that
first time you shouldn't even be wanting
to make stupid mistakes at that again it
should be a lesson do you think men
should ever say an abortion yeah yeah so
do you think if if I got pregnant and I
wanted to abort it and a guy wanted me
to keep it should he ever say yeah yeah
he has a say but you have to come to it
no like a legal say yeah like both both
parents need to sign off on the abortion
yeah that would be very practical I
think I think that is correct yeah
because she could have the baby and then
like he she might not want it say for
example I understand there's a burden in
carrying a child but we have to be
responsible in a sense mutual agreement
then yeah I get that I think that'll be
hard because it'll be easy to just say I
don't know who the father is I feel like
a lot of people would do that I feel
like a lot of people would probably say
they don't know who the father is but
there's ways to find out if they are the
father so if a man wants the child then
I think that's really unfair to take
that away from me you know I really do
definitely because when you become my
mom like you're so happy you've got baby
like for someone to steal that away from
me or like change their mind three
months in and you're so happy to take
that away and you've got no saying it
that's heartbreaking of course
but also I feel like maybe these women
would would I mean would they be
changing their minds because of
something very serious or is it just um
that women have the right to do that but
I just think at a certain point after
pregnancy there's you can't be chopping
and changing because yeah from when you
tell your man is you're pregnant like
he's in his element so to take that away
from him he's still in his dream because
it will a lot of us dream of having a
family so I just think you can't jump
and change that 50 his DNA why doesn't
he get 50 of the choice I believe he
should have 50 of the choice but then
what would happen if they don't agree
yeah no they have to agree in order for
it to happen yeah so what if one is
continue saying nope another saying yes
then it won't happen then it wouldn't
happen yeah
okay that's why I was saying they both
have to sign off for in order for it to
be an abortion
do you guys think that women should
serve jail time if they allow a man to
raise a kid that's not his 100
definitely that is so evil I think it's
so Jamaica we call that Jackie basically
you gave someone a jacket yeah that is
really really yeah it's horrible I
definitely even think that's a crime
definitely because a man imagine you're
raising that child you create a bond you
love them you give them your all
financially spiritually everything and
then to find out when they're 20. that
should be like a life sentence like an
event for 15 years and then you find out
it's not it's nice that should
definitely be punishment for that yeah
that is horrible but then on the flip
side there is we're living in a time
where guys can get DNA tests so yeah
yeah but if you've told someone it's
their child why are they going to be a
native it's illegal in France to DNA
test really oh wow I think I think it's
either they both have to sign off on it
so if the woman doesn't want him to she
can just
but that that kind of shows already if
the woman's saying no you're not yeah
some women do say no because then they
know that is the child is the man there
should be mandatory paternity test I
feel like it should be because then it
will get over the emotional thing of oh
because you're my partner because if
it's happening to everyone it's fine
yeah but I definitely think that they
should serve jail time yeah long
sentence everyone should get a DNA are
DNA test expensive yeah they're about
you're saying they should be mandatory
no I don't think that should be
mandatory to test to check that the
child's demands no I think it should I
think it's you don't think it should
yeah I think there's so many men that
are afraid to do it one because they
don't want her to freak out and I think
there's a there's a lot of guys that get
trapped in paternity fraud it's a really
common thing especially like in the U.S
yeah I just think from a government
perspective it would avoid a lot of
issues at all I know avoid having to
have the conversation because it's a
protocol for everyone do you know what I
mean I wouldn't do that and I would
never cheat on my partner like but
that's what you have I under somebody
else you know someone somebody else
might want to rule I don't think it's
fair to do that to somebody like why
would you care if the kid's his yeah I
just don't think it's fair just DNA test
them we don't need to I know that's my
man's child I'm speaking from me I
suppose I'm a selfish perspective but I
just don't think that would be fair
yeah yeah it doesn't feel right it's a
real problem in society if you have to
put that in place yeah
when you think about it there's a lot of
women that probably have done it or even
in a situation right now are actually
doing it
even until the man dies it will just
keep that they'll keep that today
there's people that do that so I'm crazy
I agree you should have we live in also
like I just want to put like a really
Niche perspective in there like I
mentioned I'm adopted
on the search for your parents if it was
done mandatory at Birth at least you'd
know like yeah true you know because you
you know I know it's such a small
minority of people but like you know you
need to be able to notice it's not
really a minority because a lot of
people must like I think it's only like
2 000 kids a year or adopted I think
there should be an option for it so 30
of paternity tests are negative wow no
way wow that is crazy
societal perspective if it's that common
of an issue that is insane and let's see
we cut it in half because you know
people getting that might be more likely
to do it let's let's cut it in half and
say it's 15 that's still one in ten yeah
that's crazy 1.5 in 10. no that's insane
no that's insane but then if DNA was
actually mandatory that might actually
put fuel to the problem anyway in the
get-go because then females wouldn't
really care about being cautious of okay
if I sleep with him you are the father
don't sleep with anybody okay mandatory
and um did DNA tests I'll just check
who's the father and bum is you just
pick who who's the father that's it so
it will add to them
they'll make them have sex with one
person more yeah because it's like I'm
not trying to go through that thing
where I give you the DNA test you're not
the massive okay some girls don't care
about that if they care about that well
I think good girls react the same but
the girls that would do that that would
probably be less likely to try to commit
paternity fraud yeah if they knew they
would get caught yeah when the baby came
out then how many good girls are there
we're not facing that much that's why it
shouldn't be mandatory yeah
wouldn't you say that's why it should be
mandatory yeah it would add to the
problem if it was mandatory I think I
don't understand how it can explain that
to me because then females would not
take precaution in who they sleep with
in in terms of it wouldn't really matter
because then their DNA tests will
actually tell them who the father is why
why would they be less they would be
less cautious because there's a DNA test
at Birth yeah because it's mandatory so
it doesn't matter who the father is it
will just tell them who the father is
and then that'll be it they can sleep
with multiple guys at the same time do
you think women are cautious now
to a degree you just said that there's
no good girl or there's very few good
girls
to a degree they actually are cautious
like they don't sleep with 10 Mana at
the same time to a degree if you had a
mandatory DNA test then they will sleep
with 10 men in one night and wouldn't
care who the father is no but you would
have to pick the dad and then you'll
give that person a DNA test and then if
he's not the dad you have to find them
because she wouldn't be speaking to a
man saying like it's your child she
wouldn't even know who the child is so
there'd be no forwarding in the first
case
[Laughter]
yeah dude I'll have to guess maybe
she'll have to wait till the child comes
out and say who does it look like the
moon you couldn't even do that though
she just wouldn't know who the dad is
because she's been with so many men yeah
oh God and it will be even more sad if
like she cheated on her partner
obviously and the partner's there so
excited yeah I did a DNA test boom
negative wait did you see that yeah or
that article where the baby um it was
like two white people the baby came out
black and she accused the guy of
sleeping with a black girl what oh yeah
that was a worry
all right
yeah I was just like what world do we
live in crazy
um okay I'm gonna read